I know it feels really bad right now
I know I feel scared and I feel alone
whatever you feel right now the emotions
like they're valid the only thing I can
do is stand here and tell you that
you're not alone all over the world
people that you didn't even know are
rooting for you are rooting for you
starting with me
what makes you unique is what makes you
beautiful it's what makes you loveable
it's what makes you incredible it's
going to be really easy right now to
feel defeated and exhausted we are
standing by you in solidarity throughout
this now is the time where it's really
important for you to stand your ground
and say this is who I am
for every person that you run into who
maybe believes that it's their right to
treat you differently you're gonna find
so many other people who will treat you
with kindness and respect and you belong
here and you can definitely make a
difference you have an inner strength
you don't even know is there but I know
it's there it just takes so much work
and so much patience you don't have to
do this alone we are so with you we're
with you
we're with you we're with you and if
America is ever gonna be great you're
gonna be the reason you are not
powerless in this you have the action to
make change read engage be voracious
volunteer with your local groups nothing
is accomplished by giving up you might
take one step back but we just have to
take two steps forward again this is not
where we stop fighting or loving or
hugging things will get better because
we are the ones that are going to make
sure that that happens but the time is
now we don't need to wait another second
don't lie down and don't accept things
that are not acceptable we will not fall
prey to hate good definitely still
exists puppies puppies puppies kittens
have you seen a kitten lately and I love
you we love you we love you we love you
we love you when people get setback
that's when they come back the strongest
and we need to stand for the things and
for the people that we believe in
you